i want to mention this too it says from
fox news a private christian school in
florida told parents ahead of the coming
school year that students will only be
identified by their biological sex and
said that students who are found
participating quote unquote in gay or
transgender lifestyles will be asked to
leave the school immediately
the email sent by grace christian school
administrator barry mckean says we
believe that god created mankind in his
image male man and female woman sexually
different but with equal dignity
therefore one's biological sex must be
affirmed and no attempt should be made
to physically change alter or disagree
with one's biological gender including
but not limited to elective sex
reassignment transvestite transgender or
non-binary gender fluid acts or conduct
students in school will be referred to
by the gender on their birth certificate
and be referenced in in name in the same
fashion
private christian school is located in
florida which is less than 20 miles
outside of tampa
and
of course this has sparked outrage
um
among many people on the left including
some of the people in the school and
parents are pulling their their
their kids out and all the rest of it
meanwhile this is of course
a wonderful thing
it's not going to surprise you to hear
me say that
this is a wonderful thing
and in fact if you here's what what you
need to do okay if you send your kid to
a private christian school and they have
not sent an email like that out
i'd be marching into the office
and print out a copy of this email and
say why haven't you sent this out
copy this email down put in your words a
little bit
send it out why haven't you
you know if if you're paying money
and private christian schools most of
them
uh i certainly know this are not cheap
and if you're paying all that money
there should be a reason behind it and
the only reason i can think of just to
spend so much money to send your kid to
a private school instead of just sending
the public school is because
not just the education but the culture
is going to be vastly different from
what they get in public school
and of course they're in christian
school so you should expect that they
are being
introduced to and uh and brought up in
christian values
although in this case of course what he
just described in that email that i mean
those are christian values but they're
also that's that's also just reality
this is biblical values
male and female he created him
but that's also science and reality all
these things work together as they so
often do
so that would be my question
if i were sending my kid to a private
christian school have you sent an email
like that out and if you have it i want
to know why
except i'll you know you can already
assume why they haven't sent it out it's
because they have no intention
of uh enforcing christian values in that
way and and they're perfectly happy to
let the insanity of modern culture
not only permeate into their christian
school environment but but define it
right
you know today's world is a scary one
too many people don't seem to care about
the truth moral standards have flown out
the window and i'd argue that's all
rooted in people becoming less religious
that's why it's more important than ever
that people take a step back from all
this craziness and keep our
relationships with god strong the best
way to do that is by praying every day
with hallow hallow is the number one
christian prayer app in the u.s it's
like calm or headspace but rooted in
catholic faith as opposed to the
religion of leftism hallo offers over
5000 audio guided prayers meditations
and christian music tracks some of the
most popular prayers include the bible
in a year with father mike schmitz
uh prayers led by mark wahlberg mario
lopez jim kavisel and also kid prayers
and meditations and much more than that
hallo helps me find my peace and calm
throughout the day it helps me sleep
better lower my anxiety levels and teach
my kids not to be terrible humans if i
seem like i've been more peaceful and
calm it's because of hello and if i
don't seem like that
don't blame hallow let hallow help you
find your peace and strength today go to
hallow.com matt walsh or text pray to
1-855-944-5684 and get an extended
three-month free trial during which
you'll have access to all 5 000
meditations and pairs that's hallow.com
matt walsh or text pray to
1-855-944-5684 for three months free
reclaim your peace in this crazy world
download hallow today what about the
people who are surprised by this
parents
again paying money
to send your kid to a christian school
and then you're surprised when the
christian school says hey this is a
christian school and we're going to
operate accordingly
how could they be shocked by that
well it's only because we've gotten used
to this idea
that lgbt people have the right to just
do whatever they want
and to do it anywhere in any situation
that they're entitled to it
that they're entitled to
living this life where people are
constantly making exceptions for them
you know talking about the speaking of
the bible they they are entitled to be
like moses
just parting the red sea everywhere they
go
everywhere they go just everything kind
of parts and accommodates them and make
special exceptions
[Music]
but that is simply not the reality
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts